[Music]
as humans we fortified war for centuries
film literature and epic poems even in
sculpture if you live in a major city
chances are there's a memorial nearby
commemorating soldiers long dead and
then there's our digital medium and in
videogames as well war is all around us
we've stormed the beaches at Normandy
defended Earth from alien threats we've
launched nuclear weapons fought the
Crusades and battled mythical foes like
many of the best stories the best games
thrive on conflict and as far as
conflict goes if you can match the
bombast and spectacle of all-out war
it lets us command armies shoot digital
guns and more often than not blow [ __ ]
up all in the name of a greater cause
but at what point does this become
redundant at what point do games use
worn-out for storytelling but merely as
a backdrop for heroics and violence at
what point does this glorification of
war get old if you're like me you've
heard the story dozens of times before a
squad takes on an army or a lone hero
save the day
and if you're like me you can appreciate
when a game deviates from this formula
when a games not afraid to take a deeper
look at war but causes realities and
consequences of it a few standout titles
have done just that
and with call duty returning to world
war two later this year and Battlefront
two story being told from the Empire's
perspective it's worth looking back to
figure out how we can move forward
[Music]
war in video games have coexisted for a
while it goes back to the arcade days
with cabinets like space invaders or
Missile Command games that despite their
technical limitations frame their simple
gameplay mechanics with a surrounding
conflict then came 1981 and with it
Castle Wolfenstein we were dropped into
a historical war a pixelated
representation of an actual time period
it would be the first of dozens of
titles set during World War two for a
while this was the norm I can't tell you
how many times I stormed Omaha Beach
defended the Russian front or dropped
into Holland to end the war before
Christmas I have relatives that fought
in World War two but these games never
bothered me on a personal level the era
was modern enough to interest me but far
enough away to ignore its realities I
like the rhythm of these games I like
the way the weapons fell in my digital
hands but that all changed in 2007
US Marines stationed on high alert
unlike previous Call of Duty games
modern warfare eschewed the world war 2
setting for that of a fictional conflict
spanning Russia Ukraine in the Middle
East it tells a story about terrorism
and nuclear weapons combining the fears
of the 21st century with those of the
Cold War but here's the thing about
modern warfare in 2007 for the first
time I was playing a shooter about a
current conflict yes the plot was
fictional but many of its missions drew
clear inspiration from events unfolding
in Iraq and Afghanistan
my brother was in Iraq at the time with
the US Marines I can't remember the
exact moment but at some point it dawned
on me
modern warfare had taken real-world
horror and transformed it into fun
imagine if they had video games in 1944
picture a 16 year old sitting in front
of his TV controller in hand invading
France while his older brother huddled
in a foxhole in Belgium this isn't too
far from what happened in 2009 developer
atomic games announced six days in
Felucia historical games set in Iraq in
2004 because of how recent the events
were the studio and publisher Konami
drew ire from the public and raise
questions about the ethics of such a
project it was subsequently canceled
under the pressure and hasn't seen the
light of day since now don't get me
wrong I love Call of Duty 4
in fact I'm playing the remaster right
now and even in 2017 it's fantastic but
my experience all those years ago raised
questions like should games like this
even be fun
is it ok to make these experiences into
trophies leaderboards and achievements
with the war games like this say about
our society or culture in general
after playing this game for the first
time in years many of my questions still
remain as it turns out I wasn't the only
one with these questions Matthew Thomas
Paine a professor at the University of
Notre Dame wrote a book about military
video games titled playing war in it he
explores how military games such as Call
of Duty battlefield and Tom Clancy's
Rainbow six have transformed
contemporary conflicts into games how
they portray military tactics yes but
also how they perpetuate widespread
political beliefs look back at the
evolution of military shooters in a vast
majority of them were fighting Germany
Japan or fascist Italy as paine
clarifies in his book these games give
us the virtual chance to stand up to our
historical enemies to be the heroes
delivering the final blow to the age-old
villains but in our post 9/11 world
things changed more frequently military
shooters asked us to wage war against
radical terrorists from places across
the world we watched CNN and saw footage
from Fallujah and Ramadi clips of
Fighters with RPGs and ak-47s we turn on
our consoles and saw the same thing this
highlights how games can reflect a
culture of our time for better or worse
our collective hopes anxieties and fears
whether they be through a realistic lens
or one tinted with fiction these are
stories that millions of people consume
and spend billions of dollars on each
and every year and this isn't consigned
to military shooters sci-fi titles like
Halo 2 and Gears of War expressed the
same fears of foreign invasion of the
enemy coming to our doorstep in halo 2
the aliens have found earth in Gears of
War the locusts have emerged from
beneath our feet these games may not
have the burden of realism on the backs
of their stories but in the end they are
telling very familiar stories and of
course many of these games glorify the
events at hand it's hard to make a war
game that doesn't inherently romanticize
war we play most games for fun escapism
or a sense of accomplishment the vast
majority of shooters are by nature going
to sensationalize their conflicts
this is nothing new film is done this
for decades in literature for centuries
once more unto the breach dear friends
valiant stories of brothers and arms
fighting the forces of evil with God on
their side authors such as Ernest
Hemingway Joseph Heller and Kurt
Vonnegut published anti-war novels that
broke down the structure and themes of
the works that came before them the film
world saw a similar change in the tide
the french director francois truffaut
once said it was impossible to make
anti-war movies with all of their
excitement and sense of adventure they
inevitably make war look fun but then
Oliver Stone made platoon Francis Ford
Coppola made Apocalypse Now
they made movies about the horrors and
realities of war and the personal toll
it can take on the human psyche and then
we have video games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in a lot of ways we are still stuck in
the past games at least most of them are
made to be fun they're made with a clear
set of rules that dictates how we
function within their worlds and in turn
within the wars they depict and many
shooters do a great job of creating fun
I enjoy the hell out of them but when I
look at other titles I'm confident we've
actually taken those first few steps
into more meaningful war stories as
Payne says in his book games more than
any other medium can pose that difficult
question when if ever is it ok to pull
the trigger few games embody that choice
more than spec ops the line at the end
of the game you realize your character
is created imaginary villain to justify
the horrific things you did in the chaos
of war and by giving you the chance to
kill the villain or spare him the game
is asking you whether you think those
actions were righteous more than that
SpecOps highlights the consequences of
war while most shooters actively ignore
them in one sequence developer Jaeger
actually makes you walk through an area
you previously shelled with white
phosphorus only to discover that you
killed dozens of civilians in the
process spec ops doesn't ignore the
ripple effects of your violence neither
does this war of mine in fact this 2014
game focuses entirely on the civilian
side of things as your group fights to
outlast the siege of a fictional city
you upgrade your shelter scavenge for
supplies and heal other survivors while
the war outside rages on the only way to
win is to survive until a ceasefire is
called and as civilians that decision is
completely out of your hands you're at
the mercy of a conflict you can't
control and then there's The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt and despite the RPGs fantasy
setting this is very much a game about
war not the battles and heroics but the
politics confusion and results of war we
speak to soldiers on both sides
each one of them believing they're
absolutely in the right we see a
landscape covered in corpses
we fight creatures that feed on the
guilt and despair of war The Witcher 3
may not show us raging battles but it
does show us the bitter aftermath in a
massive open world
to be clear I'm not saying every game
needs to say something profound about
war or the way games relate to it I'm
still gonna play this year's Call of
Duty and I'm still enjoying titanfall 2
and battlefield 1 but 2016 did see the
release of numerous shooters many of
them depicting war in one way or another
this is a pervasive genre and it shows
no signs of slowing down
war and video games are cousins I just
don't think they have the healthiest
relationship right now
that's why games such as spec ops and
The Witcher 3 are so important like any
form of art or entertainment video games
can reflect the anxieties and
aspirations of our time to act like
these multibillion-dollar properties
don't play a part in our collective
culture would be a disservice to the
medium many of us love to act like games
don't affect our perspective on war
would be to ignore their broader
potential and with battlefront 2 and the
new Call of Duty releasing later this
year I think we need to keep asking
those difficult questions and I think we
need to keep moving forward hey everyone
thanks so much for watching this week's
episode of reboot next week Jake and I
will be doing a Q&A about this episode
which focus more on war and will also be
teasing our next episode episode 6 so in
the meantime get your youtube comments
and tweet at Jake Decker or me Mike
McCarty and we might feature you on our
show see you then
[Music]